حارس بولندا تريند على تويتر عشان يوصف
الاجواء بين لاعبي البرتغال وزملاء بنزيما
ساعدونا باصابته هذه الاخبار وغيرها
تتابعونها على العربيه الرياضات اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بعد خساره المنتخب السعودي امام بولندا
تصدر وسمو حارس بولندا محرك البحث في موقع
التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر وكانت حارس
المنتخب البولندي ونادي يوفنتوس الايطالي
بعد تصده لركله جزاء سددها سالم الدوسري
والتسديده التي تلتها من محمد البريك
بالاضافه الى العديد من الفرصيره للمنتخب
السعودي
وقبل مباراه السعوديه وبولندا كان المنتخب
التونسي قد سقط امام مناظير الاسترالي
بهدف دون رد رواد السوشيال ميديا ومشجع
منتخب تونس استوى من النتيجه خاصه وانها
جاءت بعد التعادل مع منتخب الدنمارك الذي
يعد اقوى من الفريق الاسترالي لتتعاقد
وضعيه نسور قرطاج قبل المواجهه التي
ستجمعهم امام حمل اللقب منتخب فرنسا في
الجوله الاخيره من دوري المجموعات
وبعد الجدل الذي اثاره كريستيانو رونالدو
في الفتره الماضيه فضل النجم مانشستر
يونايتد سابقا زملائي في المنتخب لتناول
العشاء في احد مطاعم العاصمه القطريه
الدوحه ربما لتصفيه الاجواء قبل المواجهه
المرتقبه لهم امام المنتخب
امام غانا في الجوله الاولى
كشفت تقريبا صادم لصحيفه الفرنسيه يتحدث
عن سعاده اللاعب المنتخب باستبعاد
البنزيمه من المونديال بسبب الاصابه وقال
التقرير بان اللاعبين الاصغر سنا اصبحوا
اكثر راحه داخل غرفه الملابس فيما ضمن
الجرو وكانه كاساسي واصبح مبابي سعيدا
كونه نجم الاول في المنتخب والقاء
المسؤوليه على عاتقه
[موسيقى]